oui c'est très fort je sais pas comment
il fait mais s'est bien débrouillé ça va
casser de services bug je veux pas temps
de revoir
les cocotiers des plages de sable fin
l'eau à 32 degrés c'est exactement ce
que vous aurez pas aujourd'hui dans
cette vidéo parce que nous sommes à
saint malo pour le quatrième épisode de
mentalisme dans la rue j'imagine que
vous avez regardé la vidéo de la semaine
dernière parce que c'était une vidéo
importante parce qu'elle est longue
parce qu'il y avait des images du
spectacle
secret numéro 1 nous sommes aux abords
du château de saint malo il a été
construit en 1424 et les une
particularité est extrêmement rare les
canons sow tournée non pas vers
l'extérieur de la ville pour la défendre
mais vers l'intérieur de la ville pour
calmer les mâles - des malouins c'est
les habitants de saint malo alors pour
les calmer disons qu'ils ont un peu de
mal à respecter l'allégeance aux ducs de
bretagne et le peuple malouin est un
peuple un peu insoumis comme dirait
certaines personnes en période
électorale
par exemple en 1590 c'est le
couronnement du roi henri de navarre
sauf que il les protestants il est pas
catholique bessat ça plaît pas aux
malouins et qu'est ce qu'ils font les
malouins quand ça leur plaît pas à abbey
monté un complot ils assassinent le
gouverneur de saint malo ils prennent le
contrôle de la ville qui déclare
modestement république indépendante mais
ça marche plutôt pas mal parce que ce
port là est très important pour le
royaume à l'époque et du coup quatre ans
plus tard le roi va se plier à ça et se
convertir au catholicisme
les malouins rond une dernière exigence
que le drapeau malouin flotte plus haut
que le drapeau du royaume est encore
aujourd'hui le drapeau malouin flotte
plus haut que le drapeau français on
peut dire que c'est un peuple européen
[Musique]
salut bonjour c'est quoi ton prénom axel
axel alors attends axel je vais juste
chercher un peu d'affaires et j'arrive
tout de suite
manon c'est ça oui je vais te laisser ce
gros bloc notes et l'idée si tu
m'autorise bien sûr c'est qu'on se met
dos à dos et on va dessiner en même
temps et je vais essayer de récupérer
tes gestes alors juste avant je te
regardais te poser deux trois questions
pour me faire des indices un peu
psychologique sur toi
ta couleur préférée
c'est la réponse qui est donné dans 92%
des cas si je te demande de me dire un
outil tout de suite partout un marteau
dans 99% des cas
sas bien vous aimez saint malo retourne
et moi s'il te plaît on va se mettre dos
à dos n'ont plus fait le dessin mais en
gros un d'accord c'est quand tu veux
c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est bon pour toi là s'est terminé
alors oui on se retourne cache bien ce
que tu as fait pour l'instant j'ai samoa
alors c'est très clair que c'est
dégueulasse un ce que je viens de faire
un c'est juste une interprétation de
mouvement je vais essayer d'en sortir
quelque chose d'un peu plus cohérent est
ce que c'est quelque chose de très
carrée avec plein de d'angle par seconde
ouais non
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être ça c'est
incroyable t'es pas un objet en tout cas
pas l'objet je suis passé de ça à ça
parce que ça c'est un objet qui existe
vraiment et je me dis que ça plus de
l'inspirer tu vois hockey à trois on
retourne le dessin face à la caméra 1 2
oui âgées pas la forme des fleurs je
sais pas trop mal moi j'ai fait une
fermeture éclair moi on est sur un an on
est sur un petit smiley comme ça
directement c'est pas mal
mais le cerveau en prônant un jour
secret numéro deux il n'y a pas vraiment
d'histoire d'amour entre saint malo et
des ongs et compte beaucoup étaient en
guerre et en 1693 les anglais ils en ont
marre de se faire dominer à chaque fois
au combat par les malouins donc ils se
réunissent vraiment il monte un projet
secret ils vont appeler la machine
infernale ils vont créer un brûlot en
gros ils vont sacrifier un navire un
gros bâtiment ils vont le remplir le
bourrer d'explosifs de trucs qui foutent
le feu etc ils vont envoyer ce bateau
s'en remet à bord examen sur saint malo
pour péter les remparts une bonne fois
porteuse il envoie le bateau sauf qu'il
va pas toucher les remparts il va aller
s'écraser la tête sur un rocher au large
de saint malo et il va rien se passer
ils auront sacrifié un bâtiment
énormément d'argent et en plus ils vont
un peu se ridiculiser alors il ya une
légende qui raconte qu'il ya quand même
une braise qui a atteint saint malo et
qui atterrit sur la queue d'un chat qui
s'est mis à gigoter à tomber du mur
d'ailleurs ils en seraient morts en gros
ils ont voulu prendre une ville les ont
tué un chat et pour se moquer d'eux à
saint malo il ya une rue qui existe qui
s'appelle la rue du chat qui danse et
par rapport à j'ai un bail il ya un truc
que j'aime bien faire c'est savoir quel
jour de la semaine donc n'importe quelle
date de l'année ok genre tu me dis le 22
novembre cette année ces quelques jours
et que dire un mardi et je fais mon
petit malin comme ça en moi je te confie
c'est un almanach de toutes les années
de 1900 à 2000 voilà on a acheté ça dans
une librairie tu penses à cette date de
naissance tu prends n'importe quelle
date de naissance donc là en
l'occurrence tu es en train de penser à
ta maman oui c'est ça ok elle est née
quand exactement jour mois année elle
est née le 29 mai 1962
ouvre à la page 1962 bien sûr qu'on
gagne du temps déjà ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'en 1962 le 31 décembre on le
fêtait un lundi continuant de cendres on
le fêtait en lundi et le 5 juillet 1979
ça devait être un jeu dit à maman l'a vu
naître un jeudi c'est correct oui la
saint valentin ça tombait un mercredi
n'est ce pas le 14 février
mentalist le 29 mai 2009 162 ça tombe un
mardi oui oui c'est ça ok et ont fêté
noël à mardi également d'ailleurs allé
dans le même sens
on va voir si c'est une année qui était
un petit peu chanceuse tu vas trouver un
vendredi 13 au mois d'avril je dis pas
de bêtises un deuxième vendredi 13 où
elle aurait pu parier gros cette année
là c'était au mois deux alors la
personne va me revenir au mois de
juillet oui oui mais voilà je crois que
je crois que j'ai démontré je
connaissais 1962
ça va
troisième secret les chiens du gué de
saint malo à 22 heures à saint malo il
ya les cloches de la cathédrale qui
retentissent à partir de ce moment là
c'est couvre-feu les malouins ont quatre
minutes pour rentrer chez eux qu'est ce
qui se passe si rentrent pas chez eux eh
bien ils vont se faire littéralement
bouffer par des dogs anglais d énorme
chien qui ne sont pas nourris de la
journée qui sont lâchés à partir de 22
heures dans la ville de saint malo et
sur le port jusqu'au petit matin
pourquoi on fait ça parce que le port à
cette époque est beaucoup plus vaste et
à marée basse les bateau s'échoue c'est
à dire que vraiment il se il se penche
un petit peu sur le sol ils sont tout à
fait accessible la marchandise est en
danger et on peut pas surveiller ça
autrement en tout cas c'est le système
qu'ils ont trouvé à l'époque donc si on
rentre trop tard on se faisait attraper
par les chiens et il n'y avait pas de
quartier il n'y avait pas de cadeau les
chiens c'est devenu l'emblème de saint
malo il ya qu' en france il ya que à
saint malo que ça existait on retrouve
d'ailleurs les dogues sur le blason de
la ville et sur les plaques d'égout un
petit peu partout comme ça dans saint
malo ça va durer jusqu en 1770 où un
officier de la marine va rentrer chez
lui un petit peu trop tard il va se
faire attraper par un chien qui va le
manger et là du coup le gouvernement de
saint malo se dit on va arrêter ça on va
peut-être aujourd'hui d'autres systèmes
la fin est très triste d'ailleurs parce
qu'ils vont empoisonner les chiens au
final c'est c'est fabuleux dogues
anglais qui ont fait l'histoire de saint
malo c'est très connu ici c'est
peut-être pas connu pour vous ça
aujourd'hui à 22 heures encore ses
traditionnels les cloches de la
cathédrale ont retenti ce mais sauf
qu'il ya pas de couvre-feu évidemment
sauf quand il ya qu'eux
quand tu penses à une personne une
personne qui n'est pas ici une personne
qui existe vraiment d'un texte aussi que
cette personne là elle peut être
majoritairement dans les deux plus
grands genres le plus utilisé être un
homme ou une femme ou ok pourquoi tu me
regardes pas dans les yeux tu veux pas
donné d'indicés c'est pas simple face à
en tout cas ça peut être un homme une
femme c'est ça qui est bien parce que
quand tu fronce les sourcils sur rome ça
veut dire que c'est un homme ok c'est
déjà parti et ça c'est petit sourire là
ça s'appelle le som ça veut dire que
gérard est ce que tu peux penser à la
première lettre de cette personne ou à
n'importe quel être l'un du milieu de
son prénom n'importe quelle est celle
que tu veux plutôt une consonne ce sera
plus compliqué ok tu me regarde dans les
yeux tu penses à cette lettre cette
lettre ça peut être à z vais y cdw ev
est jugée ths large du cap et l om n
j'ai une première à l'oeil c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal c'est quelqu'un qui est
fait sur partie de ses amis
i saw 2 cette famille d'abord
peut-être bien ton père ne
me donnent des indices parce que
forcément si c'était son père avec sa
tranche d'âge je peut cumuler et
commencé à faire des stats hockey est ce
que tu pourrais dans ta tête prononcé le
tout début par exemple moi le tout début
de fabien se serait fait le juste le
tout début tu le prononce dans ta tête
je monte le volume prononcent encore
pendantes encore ce que tu peux regarder
un peu plus haut
tu
[Musique]
as réagi quand j'ai dit que c'était
quelqu'un de plus âgé que toi donc je
pense que ça fonctionne encore on peut
tenter un prénom je veux marquer ici
c'est qu'ils par rapport à toi là tu
peux me dire pour de vrai c'est ton père
j'ai vu d'autres
comment est-ce que tu as me régis régis
bawa et s'affale régis tempère secret
bonus parce que oui on a dit roy secret
mais là la ville il ya trop d'histoires
à raconter je vous racontais l'histoire
qui relie un marin un bébé une guenon
cette place c'est assez incroyable ça
s'est passé ici un marin avait ramené de
l'un de ses voyages une guenon voilà
autre époque autres moeurs autres
autorisations autre lien avec les
animaux et sept jeunes ont été enfermés
et du coup comme elle s'ennuyer alors
regarder toute la journée ce que faisait
les personnes ici principalement les
jeunes femmes parce que les hommes
étaient en mer et les jeunes femmes
s'occuper aussi principalement des bébés
et donc lagune envoyer les dames qui
berçait des bébés toute la journée un
moment donné il ya une mère qui a laissé
son bébé dans son berceau mais jusque là
tout est logique du coup là dedans elle
s'est dit bah moi je vais faire pareil
elle s'est faufilée elle a attrapé le
bébé elle est montée sur les toits pour
le bercer comme ça donc grosse panique
vous imaginez bien ici que c'était pas
la fête surtout que c'était impossible
de récupérer le bébé parce qu'on ne
pouvait pas monter sur le toit parce que
la guenon pouvait devenir agressive ou
lâcher le bébé enfin il pouvait se
passer des choses terrifiantes le bébé
avait faim donc pendant ce temps là la
guenon plutôt sympa elle prenait des
trucs dans la gouttière pour essayer de
lui mettre dans la bouche bon il fallait
intervenir assez vite et c'est une femme
qui a une idée incroyable cette jeune
femme elle s'est dit c'est sûr qu'elle
berce le bébé parce qu'elle nous a vus
faire donc j'ai essayé de faire le truc
al'inverse elle s'est emparée d'un gros
sac de linge elle s'est mis à le percer
et à le déposer dans un berceau alors
repris un autre sac de linge la verse et
la mise dans un berceau etc et en
regardant la guenon en attirant son
attention et du coup la guenon elle a
repris le système d'imitation qu'elle
avait au préalable à l'inversé le bébé
est allé aller le déposer dans un
berceau et le bébé va bien le passage
demain avec la guenon s'est bien passé
au final le bébé va très bien
aujourd'hui c'est plus tellement un bébé
je vous avoue mais l'histoire raconte
que il s'est rien passé de grave pour
lui j'ai hâte de voir dans l'espace
commentaire ce que vous avez pensé un
peu de la nouvelle formule n'hésitez pas
à nous dire on va regarder ça
attentivement on se retrouve vendredi
c'est la prochaine vidéo sur youtube
vendredi soir c'est le premier casse
tête de la rentrée et sinon bientôt dans
la vraie vie au palais des glaces en
spectacle prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]